E
RECEIVED A LOT OF ENCOURAGEMENT
AROUND THE COUNTRY FROM PEOPLE
THAT THAT CR PARTICULAR STYLE OF
LEADERSHIP. AND WE'RE GOING TO.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
REFLECT VERY DEEPLY ON ENTERING
THAT NATIONAL THAT'S FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE YESTERDAY,
TEASING A POTENTIAL PRESIDENTIAL
RUN SUGGESTING THAT REPUBLICAN
VOTERS WANT TO SEE HIM RUN FOR
PRESIDENT IN 2024. WE SHOULD
NOTE THAT COMES ALONG AND
MONMOUTH UNIVERSITY SURVEY THAT
SHOWED PENCE'S LIKEABILITY AMONG
GOP VOTERS SLIPPED OVER THE LAST
MONTH DOWN FROM 55. IN FEBRUARY
, 2023 TO 42% IN MARCH AND
ACCORDING TO OUR NEXT GUEST, A
FOCUS GROUP OF REPUBLICAN VOTERS
ALSO HAD SOME HARSH WORDS FOR
THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT. THEIR
VIEWS ARE PART OF THIS ATLANTIC
STORY HEADLINE IS QUOTE. NOBODY
LIKES MIKE PENCE. ONE VOTER OF
THE 34 THAT WERE SURVEYED
COMMENTING. I DON'T CARE FOR
HIM. HE'S JUST MIDDLE OF THE
ROAD TO ME. IF THERE WAS SOMEONE
HALFWAY BETTER, I WOULD NOT VOTE
FOR HIM. AND QUOTE. HE'S ONLY
GOING TO GET THE VOTE FROM HIS
FAMILY, AND I'M NOT EVEN SURE IF
THEY LIKE HIM. IN A STATEMENT TO
CNN, A SPOKESPERSON FOR PENCE
PUSHED BACK HEAVILY ON THE STORY
. THAT'S HARSH QUOTES. THEY'RE
SAYING QUOTE MIKE PENCE HAS IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS TRAVELING TO
MORE THAN 30 STATES, CAMPAIGNING
FOR DOZENS OF CANDIDATES AND
LISTENING TO POTENTIAL VOTERS.
THOSE INTERACTIONS HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLY POSITIVE AND
ENCOURAGING, AND WE PLACE MORE
VALUE IN THOSE EXPERIENCE. THAN
A FOCUS GROUP CONDUCTED BY
DISGRUNTLED FORMER REPUBLICANS
PAID FOR BY AN ANTI REPUBLICAN
GROUP AND ESSENTIALLY LEAKED TO
THE ATLANTIC, WHICH RECENTLY
DECLARED THAT THE GOP IS JUST
OBNOXIOUS. DO PEOPLE EVEN TRIED
TO HOLD HIDE THEIR ULTERIOR
MOTIVES ANYMORE. ONCE AGAIN,
THAT IS A STATEMENT COMING FROM
PENCE'S TEAM. ALSO JOINING US
NOW IS MCKAY COPPINS, WHO IS A
STAFF WRITER FOR THE ATLANTIC
WHO OBSERVED THE FOCUS GROUP HAS
THESE QUOTES, EXPERIENCES
VOTERS? MCKAY I JUST WANT TO
NOTE QUICKLY BECAUSE OF WHAT
ALLUDED TO IN THAT STATEMENT
THERE UM, THE FOCUS GROUPS AND
THE COSTS ARE SPLIT BETWEEN THE
BULWARK AND THE REPUBLICAN
ACCOUNTABILITY PROJECT. THOSE
ARE TWO ANTI TRUMP ORGANIZATIONS
THAT SHE'S AFFILIATED WITH YOU
NOTE THAT IN YOUR STORY, SO YOU
DO PUT ALL THAT BACKGROUND THERE
. BUT LET'S JUST START WITH WHAT
YOU SAW WHAT YOU HEARD FROM
THESE FROM THESE REPUBLICAN
VOTERS. YEAH, IT WAS REALLY
INTERESTING. YOU KNOW, THE
REPUBLICANS THAT I LISTENED TO,
AND IT WAS ACTUALLY A SEVERAL
FOCUS GROUPS. THEY ALL REJECTED
THE IDEA OF MIKE PENCE PRESIDENT
CANDIDACY WITH A COUPLE
EXCEPTIONS AND FOR ALL DIFFERENT
REASONS, SO STRONG TRUMP
SUPPORTERS WERE ALIENATED BY
PENCE BECAUSE OF HIS REFUSAL TO
OBSTRUCT THE CERTIFICATION OF
THE ELECTORAL VOTES ON JANUARY
6TH. LESS TRUMP INCLINED.
REPUBLICANS SAID THAT THEY FELT
PENCE WAS TARNISHED BY HIS TIME
IN THE ADMINISTRATION. ALL OF
THE REPUBLICANS SUGGESTED IN ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER THAT THEY FELT
PENCE WAS WEAK OR LACKED
CONVICTION. AND JUST TO GIVE YOU
ONE DATA POINT OF THE 34
REPUBLICANS ACROSS FOUR FOCUS
GROUPS THAT I HEARD DISCUSSED
PENCE'S PERSPECTIVE CANDIDACY.
ONLY FOUR SAID THEY WOULD EVEN
CONSIDER PENCE AS PRESIDENT AND
TWO OF THEM IMMEDIATELY STARTED
TO BACKPEDAL AFTER INITIALLY
INDICATING INTEREST THAT YOU
SORT OF ANSWERED THE NEXT
QUESTION THAT I HAD MCKAY AND
THAT IS THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
OR IF THE AFFILIATION WITH TRUMP
HAS DAMAGED HIM AND BEING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION BEING, YOU
KNOW A LOYAL SOLDIER, BUT THEN
AT THE END, NOT DOING WHAT TRUMP
WANTED HIM TO DO THAT AND
OVERTURNED THE ELECTION. IT IS
HURTING HIM IN ON TWO DIFFERENT
FRONTS. IT'S A TOUGH THING FOR
HIM TO HAVE TO NAVIGATE. YEAH,
THAT'S RIGHT, AND A NUMBER OF
VOTERS POINTED THIS OUT. THEY
SAID, LOOK, WHATEVER YOU THINK
OF TRUMP. NOBODY THAT I KNOW.
LIKES MIKE PENCE THAT YOU KNOW
WHAT ONE VOTER ACTUALLY SAID HE
HAS NO CONSTITUENCY. IT'S OVER.
IT'S RETIREMENT TIME, AND I
THINK THAT REFLECTED KIND OF THE
CONSENSUS VIEW OF HIM. WHAT WAS
ESPECIALLY INTERESTING IS THERE
WAS ONE GROUP I LISTENED TO WAS
CONSISTED ENTIRELY OF
CONSERVATIVE EVANGELICAL
CHRISTIANS WHO PRESUMABLY MIGHT
LIKE MIKE PENCE'S PERSONA, WHICH
IS ROOTED IN THE RELIGIOUS
RIGHT. EVEN ALL OF THEM REJECTED
PENCE AS A PROSPECTIVE CANDIDATE
, SAYING THAT EITHER THAT HE WAS
TOO WEAK OR THAT HE WAS, YOU
KNOW, NOT A FIGHTER, AND IN MANY
CASES, THEY NOTED THAT HE WAS A
NICE GUY, STRONG AND HONEST,
DECENT GUY IN THEIR VIEW, BUT
THAT THAT DIDN'T MAKE HIM
NECESSARILY A GOOD PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE. HONEST, DECENT GUIDE
DOESN'T MAKE A GOOD PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE THAT'S REALLY TELLING
IN AND OF ITSELF. WHAT I FOUND
SO FASCINATING BECAUSE YOU'VE
BEEN FOLLOWING HIM SINCE YOU
PROFILED HIM IN 2017. IS IT? YOU
TALK TO VOTERS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, SO THIS WAS NOT JUST
ONE SORT OF GEOGRAPHICAL
LOCATION. YOU WENT FROM?
SUBURBAN ATLANTA TO RURAL
ILLINOIS TO SAN DIEGO. AND I
WONDER TO DON'S GREAT POINT. IS
IT SORT OF THE PEOPLE THAT YOU
HEARD FROM THESE FOCUS GROUPS?
REPUBLICAN VOTERS FEEL LIKE HE'S
TRYING TO HAVE IT BOTH WAYS, AND
YOU JUST CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH
WAYS. YOU'RE EITHER IN TRUMP'S
CAMP OR YOU'RE OUT, BUT HE'S
KIND OF BOTH. DEPENDING ON WHAT
YOU ASKED HIM ABOUT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT. I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
I THINK THIS WAS THE FUNDAMENTAL
MISCALCULATION THAT MIKE PENCE
MADE RIGHT. HE THOUGHT THAT BY
BEING INCREDIBLY LOYAL,
INCREDIBLY WILLING TO COVER FOR
TRUMP TO DEFEND TRUMP TO OFFER
FAWNING PRAISE OF TRUMP
THROUGHOUT HIS PRESIDENCY, HE
WOULD WIN GOODWILL WITH THE
TRUMP BASE. AND THEN ON JANUARY
6TH AND YOU KNOW TO HIS CREDIT.
I WON'T TRY TO READ INTO HIS
MOTIVES. IT'S POSSIBLE THAT HE
GENUINELY THOUGHT HE WAS DOING
THE RIGHT THING BY BREAKING WITH
TRUMP ON JANUARY 6TH. BUT HE DID
IT SO LATE THAT HE DIDN'T WIN
THAT MUCH CREDIT FROM THE LESS
MAGA INCLINED REPUBLICANS
EITHER. AND SO I THINK ALL OF
THESE REPUBLICANS REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THEY ARE ON THE KIND OF
IDEOLOGICAL SPECTRUM OR WHERE
THEY ARE ON TRUMP, ALL OF THEM
SENSED OPPORTUNISM WHEN THEY SAW
PENCE AND YOU KNOW, VOTERS JUST
DON'T LIKE THAT THEY WANT A
CANDIDATE WHO THEY THINK IS
FOLLOWING HIS GUT AND DOING WHAT
HE THINKS IS RIGHT AND THEY
DON'T SEE THAT WHEN THEY LOOK AT
MIKE PENCE. I THINK IT REMAINS
TO BE SEEN. WE HAVE TO SEE THE
FULL SHAPE OF THE 2024 FIELD AND
SEE WHAT, EVEN OFFICIALLY
RUNNING IT. WELL, YEAH, HE'S NOT
OFFICIALLY RUNNING, ETC. WHAT
VOTERS DECIDE OBVIOUSLY DON'T
WANT TO GET TO THE DISSENTERS
STUFF BECAUSE BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
PENCE'S DEALING WITH THAT
FEELING NAVIGATING THAT, SO
WE'RE PEOPLE LIKE GOVERNOR
DESANTIS, AND HE IS SPEAKING OUT
IN HIS MOST WIDE RANGING
CRITICISM WE HAVE SEEN OF TRUMP
, YET HE RESPONDED TO SOME OF
THE NICKNAMES THAT TRUMP GAVE
HIM. YOUR FAVORITE NICKNAME THAT
TRUMP'S GIVEN YOU SO FAR AS IT
RUN, RHONDA, SANCTIMONIOUS OR
MEATBALL ROCK. WHY CAN'T EVEN HE
WENT OFF MEATBALL WRONG? I CAN'T
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO SPELL THE
SANCTIMONIOUS. I DON'T REALLY
KNOW WHAT IT MEANS. BUT YOU
KNOW, I KIND OF LIKE IT'S LONG.
IT'S GOT A LOT OF VALVE. I MEAN,
SO WE GO WITH THAT. THAT'S FINE.
YOU KNOW, YOU CAN CALL ME AND
YOU CAN CALL ME WHATEVER YOU
WANT. I MEAN, JUST AS LONG AS
YOU, YOU KNOW, ALSO CALL ME A
WINNER. MAKE IT. WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF THAT? AND ALSO I'M GOING
AFTER TALKING ABOUT TRUMP'S
CHARACTER, HIS LEADERSHIP. AND
THE DIRECT CRITICISMS WE'RE
SEEING. I THINK THE SANTIS IS
TRYING TO WALK A FINE LINE AND
THESE FOCUS GROUPS VOTERS
REPEATEDLY EXPRESSED THAT THEY
DIDN'T LIKE THAT TRUMP WAS
CONSTANTLY ATTACKING OTHER
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES. OTHER
REPUBLICAN FIGURES THEY WANT
PARTY LOYALTY. THEY WANT PARTY
SOLIDARITY, AND THEY LIKED THAT
DESANTIS HAS MANAGED TO AVOID
BEING IN THE FRAY WITH TRUMP, SO
I THINK HE'S IF HE'S GOING TO
END UP RUNNING AGAINST TRUMP IS
GOING TO HAVE TO DRAW THAT
CONTRAST. BUT I THINK HE'